les chéris je lis l'avenir dans le
cassoulet et andré ac non c'est pas
c'est très sérieux je vous dis allez
médium depuis ses 11 ans elle est
présidente du salon de la voyance à
marseille elle est là des intuitions
sous la forme de flash
elle est capable de réaliser des
prédictions avec le son de la voix en
observant une personne en lui touchant
la main elle est capable de le faire les
yeux bandés et pourquoi le cassoulet
preuve d'arriver à dire dans le
cassoulet mais le cassoulet c'est notre
amie evelyne thomas qui a eu cette idée
lorsqu'on en a discuté g10 du cassoulet
du couscous n'importe quoi d'accord et
on est arrivé avec un bol de kasmi alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire une
prédiction pour chacun de nos nominés
piocher m'approche d'elle vous avez vous
approché d'eux ils vont toucher la
saucisse et ça c'est ce qu'on m'a dit je
vous dis alors le cassoulet la wii avait
tout préparé alors et bar à lisier alors
on va démarrer par la regarder si
d'accord donc très moral mais c'est donc
ce soir donc on va faire ici mal là donc
allé voir alors j'en voyais assad est
venu allez-y n'empêchèrent tu peux réel
via vers toi alors et vous allez voir
c'est impressionnant parce que vraiment
elle arrive à lire dans le cassoulet
andrea andrea vous vous lisez l'avenir
dans le cassoulet vous avez vous voulez
en fait parler de benjamin oui et de
daniel se sont effet semé mais entre jeu
si mal et givet d'or à ce couple avec le
partage d'un côté oui on va se faire un
cassoulet alors prends ça oui et tu tout
ce que tu veux c'est ce que tu fasses
aussi voilà laisse tomber ses boersch
alors attention parce que yann si j'ai
pas si tu fais du ski ou du sport
violent mais toute façon il jambe cassée
ou la fin du rivage en cas c'est aux
parents la route ni en fin novembre un
nom assez alors donc ces gars
non mais on le mettra des chaussures
antidérapantes d'accord permet pas de
gants pour le dire mais ses gaffes banon
mais qu'est ce que je vais faire la
marque des grands il as cassé la jambe
et se casse la jambe
ouais c'est qu'il nomme c'est la mienne
quand même on doit répartir en laponie
famille parce que nous on part sur après
il ya des sélectionnés vous avez perdu
votre place mais s'il part et
apparemment il va être lui va être en
angoisse tout le séjour
je suis désolé non monsieur gilles et
économe vous rencontrer mais royal à
l'étude
donc c'est tout ce qu'elle a besoin
parce qu'elle voit des flashes et sur
lui vous voyez qui va te péter la jambe
que ça ma mère si on l'a écouté et à une
rencontre aux orres non un homme d'une
cinquantaine d'années ouais italien non
oriane l'italien de larabia les deux
italiens d'aironi
parce que jacques hopin moinuddin qui
travaille dans une pizzeria
quatre enfants elle à la fin de l'année
pour noël pour les fêtes de fin d'année
et au printemps tu as quelqu'un dans ta
vie non qui ne sera pas là tout le temps
à ajaccio j'aime bien ça le côté un peu
un terme aux tensions assez mais ça veut
pas soit une semaine après on ne voit
pas pendant une semaine mais sur quoi il
se mêle et bien on trouve ça mal à des
petits moments ça va mais voilà ça nos
merdes manque du oui comment vous êtes
vie n'est pas ce que c'est un peu ce que
je vois la sauce au sang chaud à la
saucisse et méditerranéen de ces
réactions italien je me rappelais arabe
il a des deux moi j'aime bien bringer d
origine italienne moyen moyen moyen
l'italien bah merci bon très bon bref
hollandais savais que tu as juste père
noël alors parce qu'il faut que je me
tienne bonjour les prédictions sur les
yeux ou pas dû ces dernières une
dernière poussée de l'or oui oui et que
pour la profession allait animer leur
jardin petit peu je passe une saucisse
hurle à la pâleur attend merci les gars
là tu vas signer un contrat ya un
constat qui s'initient mais ses gaffes à
tous ces gens qui sont autour de toi là
tu vois me donne mon argent je sais pas
s'ils veulent ton argent mais on ne lui
veulent ils veulent quelque chose alors
quand on a signé ce contrat
c'est pour un truc important en début
d'année c'est très très important mais
né citoyen naru deux là dedans comme ta
100 millions séparent oui oui c'est télé
etc
ses gaffes parce que y'en a deux là
dedans qu'il faut virer sans merci merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]